am oui bah oui
il
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît arrêtez je suis tanné je
m'ennuie c'est les jambes et éruptions à
laquelle on s'attend pas vraiment lors
d'une remise de prix scientifique mais
c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne à la
cérémonie benigno belle parodie des prix
nobel qui récompense les études les plus
invraisemblables savez lieu jeudi soir
exact et donc on va revient sur
l'événement à notre chronique
scientifique avec renault ce matin
bonjour les calories tout d'abord dire
que c'est une cérémonie très
particulière mais on récompense des
études sérieuses oui ça faut le dire
même si toutes les études dont je
parlais au cours des prochaines minutes
vont voir leur assez spécial c'est tout
des études qui ont été publiés dans des
grandes revues scientifiques donc la
science que derrière elle est valide et
le les prix ig nobel c'est vraiment une
grande fête qui souligne l'importance de
la science
insolite donc leur slogan du concours c
on célèbre la science qui fait rire puis
réfléchir et l'objectif des ig nobel
c'est vraiment de montrer que la science
s'est pas uniquement quelque chose qui
arrive nous qui est incompréhensible la
science y en a partout autour de nous et
il ya des chercheurs qui vont
s'intéresser à des détails de son
apparence insignifiants ça ils vont
faire avancer leur curiosité ils vont
faire des expériences et ça ça peut
mener à des découvertes qui vont être
publiés et tout se passe selon les
concepteurs du prix nobel leur cérémonie
pour rendre le travail des scientifiques
plus approchable aux yeux de la
population générale que les grandes
études qui sont récompensés lors des
prix nobel et sa baisse et c'est aussi
pour ça que c'est important pour eux que
ces études ne tombe pas dans l'oubli
qu'on en parle quand même donc la
science vraiment décomplexée c'est très
très décomplexée effectivement il
cérémonie qui se prend pas au sérieux du
tout ça c'est ça c'est vrai l'offre on
est vraiment dans une soirée qui à
l'opposé de la toute la rectitude qu'on
retrouve dans les prix nobel donc il ya
quand même des différentes catégories de
prix on a les prix de chimie de physique
de médecine
ça sera jusqu'au prix d'économie il ya
même le prix ig nobel de la paix mais
pour ce qui est du reste c'est vraiment
une cérémonie qui rempli de détails
complètement absurde par exemple on le
voyait au début avec la petite fille qui
disait arrêté jugement émis
d'habitude quand les gagnants des
passent leur temps limite au niveau des
remerciements d'autres cérémonies vont
juste mettre la musique pour couper ce
qu eux il y envoie cette petite fille là
pour des recherches invoqué tant qu'il
est temps que s'arrête ce genre de
choses qui coupe court une conversation
un enfant qui utilisent encore dix ans
pis ils reçoivent aussi un prix
monétaires qui ont une valeur de 10
trilliard de dollars zimbabwéens ça
cette monnaie lors c'est le mot n'existe
plus depuis 2009 et qui aucune valeur
bon ok donc beaucoup de d'image comme ça
qui font sourire à mes parents des
études qu'elle gagne à queue sans
vraiment démériter pour la 29e édition
qui a eu jeudi une des études que
vraiment le plus fait le tour du monde
on en a beaucoup parlé dans différents
médias dans la journée de vendredi c'est
le prix d'anatomie société remis à deux
chercheurs français qui ont publié une
étude sur la symétrie thermique des
testicules donc la rue ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est des chercheurs en fertilité
masculine
ils ont montré qu'il y avait une
différence de température entre le
testicule droit et le testicule gauche
chez des hommes habillés ou sans
vêtements chez ils ont étudié soucier
des post it qui est habitué de rester
debout et chez les chauffeurs d'autobus
qui sont habitués de rester longtemps
assis oxyde nitrique qui en apparence
pour avoir l'air complètement inutile
mais vu que c'est cherchons en fertilité
masculine
mais on montre faut rappeler que là la
température des organes génitaux c'est
très important pour la production de
spermatozoïdes et en montrant qu'il ya
une différence entre le côté droit et le
côté gauche mais elle pense qu'ils
peuvent augmenter la fiabilité de
futures études sur la fertilité donc ça
peut paraître invraisemblable mes yeux
n'est inutile qu'il en est vraiment
plusieurs viols prix nobel et prix ig
nobel pour mélanger le prix ig nobel de
la paix qui a été donnée à des
chercheurs britanniques qui ont mesurer
l'intensité du plaisir qu'on ressent en
ce gratin et les plaisirs et les parties
du coeur qui était le plus affecté par
le processus il ya des le prix
d'économie qui est ce cet effet donné
pourquoi d'abord pour le savoir ensuite
ça peut avoir une utilité pour les
personnes qui souffrent de démangeaisons
chroniques et qui elle se gratter qui
peuvent pas sentir de soulagement après
voilà l'utilité il ya le prix d'économie
qui était donné des chercheurs
néerlandais qui ont montré que plus de
compo de polymères plastiques qui entre
dans la composition de billets de banque
plus ses billes elop on de risque de
transporter des bactéries résistantes
aux antibiotiques
il ya des chercheurs qui ont montré des
chercheurs italiens qui ont montré que
manger de la pizza
ça peut aider ça peut aider nous
protéger de certaines maladies mais
seulement c'est le fait maison en italie
est le bon ici les chercheurs disent que
ça ne sera pas acquis important cela dit
méditerranéenne que la pizza elle-même
est finalement une équipe internationale
qui ont montré que le web bat ça c'est
un petit animal un petit marsupial qui
qu'on peut le voir sur l'écran ciena qui
ressemble à une marmotte
oui c'est un cet animal là c'est aussi
le seul animal qui fait des excréments
de forme carrée personnes savaient
pourquoi et les chercheurs ont expliqué
le phénomène ici donc ça c'est genre
d'étude qui récompensait pendant les
prix nobel excellent et puis on le
rappelle c'est de la science qui est
valide très sérieuse c'est régulier dans
des magasins de séance
c'est exactement ce n'est pas parce
qu'une question pour avoir l'air absurde
que la science derrière elle à l'époque
voilà la leçon de ce matin fait plaisir